i get emotional when i talk about nfl
films because steve sable without steve
sable and nfl films
nfl network does not exist it is that
simple
it is that simple and then when i hosted
nfl the grind on epics
michael wright the president of epochs
gave me the opportunity to do
this show and i'm like who's
who who's the producers of the
production house he said nfl films i'm
like
in and then when i first did a voiceover
over a spinning football a tight shot of
spinning football i showed it to susie
my wife i'm like
this is a childhood dream
come true a childhood dream come true
and this is the only way i could set up
this man who's part of the nfl
the grind on epic show and he was there
for the nfl 100 all-time team show
essentially that's how deep the roster
was he was essentially a segment
producer of bill belichick's
for that show but outside of all that
he's the vice president and senior
coordinating producer of nfl films and
the director
of the latest for 30 for 30 al davis
versus the nfl
thrilled to have as a guest on the rich
eyes and show ken rogers how are you ken
i'm doing great i i sort of feel like a
guest at dinner that forgot a casserole
dish
i don't have i do not have a
championship trophy
yes you can feel a little empty-handed
can
let me tell you this story you may not
know it but when for the nfl
100 all-time team show uh
as you know they set up like this mini
photography area
in a small kitchenette that was off of
the dining area that
was set up as the green room uh for for
us to have
breakfast and lunch because it was a
long day so i'm standing there with bill
belichick
taking photographs with bill okay like
these are promotional photographs with
bill belichick words i never thought i
would say
ever okay and so we're taking
photographs bill and i and
we he points to the top of the
kitchenette
like a there's there's a a cabinet and
small space above the cabinet
and he points and resting up there are
two emmy awards
and bill says to me they have so many of
these they're putting them on top of
cabinets around here
is what he said so true you've got
a lot in the trophy case sir
yeah i think we're up to 131 and
i think as you uh as you pointed out uh
that's that's all due to steve sable for
sure
you know ken it's it's amazing man when
when um
and then we'll get obviously to the 30
for 30. for big time
nfl network events thursday night
football whatever and you hear the
hallmark it's a television phrase which
is the shot of nfl
nfl network um logo he goes you're
watching
uh a production of nfl network it's
steve sable and i get goosebumps even
just talking to you about it
ken rogers right now i i am not alone
many uh employees of nfl films when we
hear that
tear up i i still do
when his birthday comes around of course
but
any big game any big situation any
player
comes around a big play all of us think
about
what steve would say how he would react
he really was the historian of the game
he and his father created a company that
would preserve the history of the game
and without it many of us wouldn't have
the memories that we do of the game you
know when you think of the immaculate
reception you don't think of
the newspaper account you read about the
game
you don't think about the broadcast that
you saw
because it wasn't broadcast all around
the country
you remember the nfl films recap
you know they invented the highlight
package they invented
the wiring of coaches and players
they invented the slow-motion replay i
mean
they invented the follies film yes
it's amazing what they created for all
of us
not just in our childhoods but that
continues today
ken rogers here on the rich eisen show
wearing many hats for nfl films vice
president senior courting producer and
the director
of the new 30 for 30 available now on
espn plus and disney now
al davis versus the nfl i you know what
when i heard that this was going down
and you were directing it i'm like this
is must see
television and this is also television i
can't believe we are seeing
it could you i i if i had told you
maybe at the outset of your tenure at
nfl films hey
the nfl is going to be yeah that sounds
like a 30 for 30. what if i told you
that you were going to actually do a
film on al davis suing the nfl
i mean this is crazy that this is
actually going down
right now true i mean the fact that we
could tell this story is a testament to
the nfl opening up
its archives and you know it's 40 years
old now but there's some
incendiary stuff in here i mean when you
talk about
an uh an owner of a team suing the
national football league and insulting
the commissioner of the league on the
courthouse steps i mean
it's amazing and then another owner
testifying against al davis and having a
heart attack while on the stand
i mean this is equivalent think about
today if gary jones was testifying
against robert kraft and while he's
doing so he has a heart attack and is
wheeled out
and then robert kraft comes out onto the
courthouse steps
and says he has no respect for roger
goodell uh
because he has led the nfl down the
wrong path and he's suing them
i mean it it was insanity and it would
blow up twitter today
if it happened and it was great to
revisit that the wild west of
nfl business practice if there was only
such a thing as an
al davis account yes sir i agree with
you ken rogers yeah
it would be so what is one of a kind
what did you learn from this
is anything that you learned from from
this uh documentary
here's what i learned and i think it's a
great lesson for all of us
um and you certainly knew al and and
those of us who
i only met him briefly but those of us
who
mostly heard stories see him as a
as a rebel a contrarian
an outlaw maybe but he was not a bad guy
he was actually a really good guy and
i think it's easy to see people who
fight authority
and go against the norm and see
differently than you do
certainly these days in america it's
easy to see
opponents as enemies because they see
things different
differently than you do and pete and al
fought tooth and nail i mean roselle
davis was the war to end all wars for
decades
but at the end of the day when pete
rozelle retired
in this film you see it al davis
has one of the most heartfelt
soliloquies about
his opponent and describes them hugging
physically hugging and even mentions the
word love
and you realize that back then
opponents didn't mean good and bad
they respected each other there was
actually even love for each other
um even though they went to court and
and sued each other
and disliked each other on many levels
um they didn't let it go into
hatred and vitro uh the way i think
it's easy to do in today's world and and
with today's social media al davis
versus the nfl new 30 for 30 director
from nfl films ken rogers here on the
rich eisen show it was a choice no doubt
for you to in in a way bring roselle and
al davis back to life
um by i guess bringing their faces
and putting them putting them on on
bodies and um there's a photograph up
that i'm describing right now
um for the note for our radio audience
no doubt the enrapt
uh audience on raider nation radio 920
am in
vegas uh where you've got i guess that
that al davis torch that is in the new
stadium
there in las vegas nevada behind you why
did you decide to do this and how did
you
do this like what was that about ken
well i figured i'd risk my career
you know at a certain point you gotta go
for it right right
listen um the simple answer is
al davis and p roselle are no longer
with us and
we felt like this was their story to
tell um
and you know who knows one day a long
time from now maybe you'll still be
you'll still be on the air 100 years
from now uh
you know reporting as a deep fake
version of yourself i have no idea where
technology is going rich
but in the old days we would have just
hired actors to tell
us to have al davis and pete rozelle you
know come back and tell their stories
themselves that's
that's what many films documentaries
have done in the past but
instead of putting masks or prosthetics
or
makeup and trying to do it that way
we've decided to do it digitally
and you know it's the same thing that
star wars
used to bring back princess leia after
carrie fisher died and
and that martin scorsese used to make
robert de niro look
younger fake technology
um certainly a burgeoning
technology something that's getting
better and better every day
and we decided to do it technically and
it was really fun to try and be the
first sports documentary to do it
a doubt will be the last and i think
they'll probably be
sportscenter commercials using you and
stu
50 years from now you know that you'll
look uh you look like you're a
fresh-faced 25-year-old what does it
mean
what does it mean though ken that people
think i'm a deep fake right now what
does that mean for my career i don't
know it's very
but you know in all seriousness though
let's be honest steve sable would love
this you're using a scorsese film
uh production concept in in an nfl film
documentary
for for espn like something that that
lucas
did like this is this is films it's
that's why it's called nfl
films like this is exactly what steve
sable would want you to do
ken he loved technology he loved new
tools
and most of all he loved taking chances
um he really when when he was
really sick at the end of his life he
wanted us to
be proud of what nfl film stood for
but push forward in the future and try
to make our own legacies and
one of the things he always did at nfl
films
is give away every year a
cash bonus for the most
magnificent failure of the year
and that was the failure
that was no doubt
a failure but was magnificent
in its attempt and uh
i still fight for that award even though
he's not here to give it out
i still i still take pride in in
once in a while trying to win that cash
award that he used to pass out
in an envelope and i did win it once in
a while and it was always
was always to me as important as an emmy
because it meant that you were willing
to take the chance
you were willing to fail and he sold
great value
in that and uh you know i didn't get the
cash this time but
i was willing to go out there and fail
um and i don't think we did
i think it was a magnificent attempt
and uh and i think it succeeded ken
rogers here on the rich eisenshire
director of al davis versus the nfl
check it out espn plus and disney now
and
while we're still on the subject of
sable uh which i who i could talk about
for hours
you know hosting nfl the grind on epics
with you and paul camerata and the rest
of the nfl films crew behind it
uh when i was like hey let's do the end
of show essay on x y and z
and then you would dive into steve
sable's note card system
where he would just pull stuff from
periodicals or articles or just write
down
quotes that george patton once said or
what orwell once said
and put it on a card that was labeled
like tom brady or
or labeled tom landry and he would file
it away and would pull it out so he
could use it for himself and you gave
this to me
to help me write oh god i'm getting
goosebumps just talking about it ken and
on occasion
chris brockman my producer can attest we
would we would put that stuff on the air
here
i mean and
so that card system still exists correct
as well it does
i mean his office still exists uh very
much like it did the day he passed and
i mean it was the internet before the
internet yeah he would
he would read dozens of newspapers
on a daily basis he of course was a
voracious reader of novels and
and everything else periodicals and he
would write down quotes
that would be in an article about uh
napoleon
it would be a quote about napoleon but
he would
see that it applied to doug flutie
because
doug flutie is a good example
and he would put it in a in a file
under doug flutie's name and
still to this day if we're writing about
doug's footy or we're writing about
coaches in general he has files for both
big picture general like failure or
close games or overtime
subjects like that but also individuals
that
now we we may forget because they're
they played in the 60s or 70s or 80s
when he was at his
height so in a way he's still with us
and
really giving us his opinions on a lot
of subjects
all right before i let you go ken i know
i'm going to put you on the spot here by
asking this question but
you know you've been there before so
what sable once told me steve sable once
told me
that i think it might have been 15
somewhat years ago that there is in fact
an archive
tape of outtakes of john fasenda cursing
a blue streak
um and that exists and i asked him can i
hear it he said no will anybody ever
hear it he said forget that
never have you ever heard it have you
ever heard that
i have not i have not but yes
i'm gonna go looking for it now
it's somewhere you know we've already
established he's kept everything
he said that for senda whenever he would
like you know it wasn't one take john
uh you know we're very rare anybody does
it in one take he said that for senda
whenever he would maybe get caught up on
a line that he couldn't nail
to his liking he would just like curse
up a blue streak and those
outtakes exist man would i love to hear
those those
would be phenomenal man that sounds like
a new 30 for 30.
the search of the lost for sender blue
streak tips
i would love to help with that
production right you know i know you
were
unbelievable uh thanks very much ken
appreciate the time
um i love chatting with you um let's
let's let's talk soon about everything
and everybody should check out al davis
versus the nfl
again on espn plus in disney now thanks
for the time
true pleasure thank you rich right back
at you at ken rogers nfl
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here